we can do it you can do it i'm doing
some shows and that is uh albuquerque
may 18th midland
may 19th in texas lubbock texas may 20
dallas texas may 21 and a show has been
added there and selling well almost sold
out thank you guys so much for that
support
savannah georgia june 2nd augusta
georgia june 3rd montgomery alabama june
4th columbus georgia june 5th if you
have friends over there in georgia
you know people that have that love
georgia you tell them about it
hollywood florida june 23rd fort myers
florida june 24th daytona beach and
lakeland june 25th and 26th
um grab your tickets at theovonn.com
t-o-u-r that is the safest and best
place to get them thank you guys so much
in advance uh for your support and i
look forward to seeing you on the return
of the rat tour
today's guest holds a unique job in the
world and it's um
it's that job when
when there's a fire or a
murdering
or a
hoarder
or trauma
somebody's going to go into those spaces
and um and clean up
somebody's got to go do the the
dirty work baby you know somebody's got
to be that little shawshank baby
crawling through the muck
and uh and we have that man here today
he is a trauma restoration man
and he's out of minneapolis and we're
grateful for him
today's guest is trauma restoration man
mr bobby cotton
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah where are you from rob minneapolis
oh nice dude yeah we went out there and
did some shows not too long ago
uh minneapolis is so strange now it
feels like like the downtown it feels
deserted yeah they're making everyone
like the city and the state is actually
after businesses to bring people back to
the cities really
yeah they want them back in the offices
because they uh
like all the like there's nothing down
there it's just deserted so like all the
little businesses and shops are all
closing down because no one's down there
yeah it's like the mute it's like a
bunch of murals and nothing else yeah
i'm funny it's like that everybody left
and they just drew people in the
buildings
yeah and
and you know they had all the george
floyd stuff all them riots that happened
yeah man it was just the whole vibe down
there it was crazy everything got
smashed out you know because i you know
in restoration like a big part of what i
do is like when there's a fire a window
gets broken i run out in the middle of
the night and boarded stuff up oh really
i mean [ __ ] i mean i was i was working
like 120 hours a week boarding up all
the
all the buildings i had you know 300
sheets of plywood going up a day it was
crazy well so you're saying so um
i'm sitting here with rob cotton and
he's a uh
trauma restoration man
and so
you're saying that during the um and
we're gonna get into your job we just
started chatting uh
so in minneapolis during the george
floyd stuff you guys were going out you
guys go out and board stuff up yeah yeah
so whenever there's a you know riot you
know we do board up so anytime there's a
fire or there's a robbery or something
you know you got to secure those
buildings
and uh during the george floyd stuff we
were doing stuff preventatively people
were worried about getting robbed and
there was a lot of looting and stuff so
i mean we're boarding up and securing
buildings trying to prevent people from
smashing the windows in wow i mean we
were working like 24 hours a day taking
naps in the truck dang yeah it was bad
were there certain things you would
write on the certain boards
to kind of keep people out where they're
like you know like uh
was there any like kind of trickery like
that like verbal word trickery i mean we
didn't do anything like like that but a
lot of the business owners you know they
put on like minority owned or you know
we support blm or lots of stuff got put
on those boards and
yeah i don't know uh i don't know if
there was trickery or not i don't know
if people were maybe a little dishonest
on that but yeah yeah that people were
putting stuff on there wow
yeah because i guess you you most people
think that just businesses go and do
that for themselves but do you get hired
by businesses to do it yeah so either by
the insurance or
if they're in a really high risk area
like their insurance company might uh
call to have the boards put up as to try
and prevent the loss you know because
it's obviously you know when the
buildings get burned and stuff like that
sometimes the the losses or the
insurance claims are millions of dollars
so for
five or ten thousand dollars you can get
all your windows boarded up
that could save you that could really be
the difference between um your whole
business going down yeah absolutely i
mean there was a
there was a liquor store they
they're right in minneapolis there and
they lost like 1.5 million dollars in
inventory plus there was a fire in the
building oh yeah well that's the problem
you get a little bit of liquor and you
want to have somebody wants to have a
doral or you know yeah or you know roll
up a john or something and the next
thing you know the whole place is going
up oh it's crazy and i mean even you
know i had a gun pulled on me when i was
cleaning graffiti down there uh-oh yeah
and why'd they do it
uh they were just unhappy i was taking
down graffiti and i mean you know
whether or not that's out of turn i
don't care if you put more graffiti up i
got hired to take the graffiti down the
second i leave you can do it again right
right yeah you're just doing your job
yeah
so just just doing your job is really i
mean your job is
um
basically like your job is basically
restoration
trauma cleanup
how do you
like give me an example of kind of what
that entails sort of let's start well so
like the the name of the industry is
restoration and so restoration could be
fire water mold
trauma
um so it can be anything from a natural
to disaster to a pipe burst or you know
the
the ground thawing outside or suicides
murders and stuff like that basically if
something terrible is happening you're
building where the guy's a call
and do you guys go in there feeling like
the ghostbusters do y'all just feel like
a bunch of like
uh garbage men is there kind of a vibe
that you feel kind of going into a
certain environment no one is ever happy
to see us okay you know because okay you
know it's like and then fires are
generally the worst i mean
like when you do a trauma cleanup you're
not normally seeing anyone
that lives there or anything like that
because they're typically almost always
gone okay um but like when you're doing
a fire cleanup or something you know and
everyone's personal belongings
everything every picture every birth
certificate everything's gone and you're
shoveling it out with snow shovels
you know it's it can be
tough
okay so stuff like that environments
like that where you're cleaning up a
place and there's a lot of personal
effects there it really gets pretty it
probably you know it probably squeezes
your heart huh you used to i mean it's
it's hard you get really desensitive to
it desensitized to it yeah yeah so take
take me like into um an example like you
go to a company something's happened you
go to a business take me into some
trauma clean up yeah well so just use
that as an example so it's middle of the
night it was a manufacturing facility
and there was a lathe
so lathe you know you make like like for
example like a baseball bat so it spins
a piece of wood and you're cutting on it
a lathe lathe yep okay and bring that up
raleigh if you can on the screen here
okay so something like that yep yep so
just like that piece of machinery yep
that green one is just about the same
one there okay and uh so the guy was
wearing uh a glove
and so he ended up getting caught in
that and so it pulled his skin off from
like his elbow
all the way off his hand it's called d
gloving and so that got caught in there
so it spun around because obviously it's
still spinning so the thing's just
spinning around with the
yeah they spin like crazy speeds like
thousands of rpms wow red rover red
rover boy yeah yeah and uh danny right
over that's so so this thing's still
spinning you guys you guys get called in
the guy's been de-gloved d-gloved and
that means so the skin just peels off
like if you had a glove on you took it
off except that's your skin
and so i was spinning and obviously we
shut out by the time we got there but
that blood was all over everywhere so it
was all you know the ceiling's 25 30
feet tall
and it was a big manufacturing facility
so they didn't want to shut it down so
it'll you know hang plastic all around
where we were cleaning and all that
stuff had to be scrubbed down and
repainted
okay so you guys hang plastic around the
actual site of whatever's going on yeah
if they don't want to shut it down dang
they got to keep that money coming in
huh yeah so i mean the whole time it was
really crazy you know we're cleaning
skin out of this machine and on the
other side of the plastic you can hear
people talking
and what type of uh what were they
making in there overall you think you
know honestly i'm not sure
okay
yeah i'm not i'm not positive maybe
you're like a cabinet shop or something
yeah
it was a woodworking facility okay wow
and so you guys get called in something
like that what do you do with the actual
do you actually take the skin the hand
yeah so anything that's like affected
and there's a bunch of different like
categorizations of like materials so
like wood that gets
impacted really needs to be cut out and
replaced but like concrete you can clean
that so anything that gets
you know that we have to cut out and
throw it away you put it in these
special bags and then you put that in a
biohazard box and then a carrier that
specially disposes of that takes it away
and typically they're going to go to
like an incinerator okay oh wow so that
thing it doesn't get returned to the
rightful owner it gets they the skin
yeah no
you're not getting that skin back damn
have you ever had an employee try to
sneak off with something sneak off with
a thumb or something
never
a rotting thumbnail yeah or just a
middle finger maybe they're just going
to pull it out at the bar so no no that
would be something though so you guys
hang up the plastic and you guys go in
there as a team if there's some type of
a trauma like in a workplace or or any
place really um and so how long does
something like that take like are you
guys they try to send you in in the
middle of the night and get it done fast
do they so it really depends so there's
certain things like manufacturing
facilities and stuff because like a big
manufacturing facility you know they
might be making a million plus dollars a
day yeah hundreds of thousands of
dollars an hour and products oh yeah
i'm trying to think of some different
ones
hormel
trying to think of different anything
mitsubishi
trying to think of any other i mean
there's tons of oh yeah yeah yeah i mean
even a good buddy of mine had a call out
to florida uh for a machine that broke
down and it was a kitkat machine they
made kick hits yeah like and i saw a
little video of it i mean it's just
millions of cupcakes and you know who's
eating all these kitkats yeah and
they're all under they're all stressed
because the kitkat line is shut down
like the world's going to end up
don't have any cats well squirrels love
them dude my dad he used to sometimes go
park his car at the park and he would
get like a um
he had a buddy that used to get kind of
old kit kats
and they were like a couple years old
kind of but they you know you could
still eat them but the chocolate was
turning white a little you know what i'm
talking about fermented i don't know if
it i mean i don't know if it had become
like alcoholic or not but i know it had
uh it was a little bit decrepit bring up
uh
old chocolate
please
yeah old chocolate aged
like a nice fine there you go click on
one of those raleigh
oh no that's too old uh yeah that's
molded out just give me something that
um
give me something that i should have had
at christmas you know
nope
okay but i'll say this is that uh so
yeah anyway we would get the kitkats
we'd take them to the park and the
squirrels would come eat them man
squirrels love them and we they would
see squirrels jumping from just miles
away just in the distance you could see
squirrels just hopping over trying to
get them
so squirrels love them but um so anyway
you guys get called in any type of
environment
right
and so that's like an example of like a
business uh
of like a kind of a travesty that
happened at a business uh and
what is do you have a pager on you how
do they
just phone calls
i am just absolutely trained now i mean
you can call me at three o'clock in the
morning i'm not even awake yet and i got
the phone to my ear wow
and so take me on to taking on another
journey of like what uh
what a trauma restoration man gets
well i mean i would say for the most
part it's people that have been deceased
for a long time okay uh almost always
it's the post carriers that are calling
it in for a wellness check yeah because
no one's picked up the mail for a week
or a month or whatever that happens to
be can't get any more mail in the mail
slot and they're calling for the
wellness checks
so i mean
you know you get a call and and those
aren't really pressing you know that's
not like a 3am call if someone's been
dead for a month right that's a
voicemail more
yeah yeah and uh so it's kind of wild
you know when someone dies
first you like bloat up
and uh then as you decompose it like
goose starts coming out of everywhere
so it can be real bad where it's like
you know they might have died on a bed
or a couch or something that couch will
be soaked
with stuff you know goo with human goo
and so that goo is what all is it plasma
feces blood everything and then just you
know your insides decomposing on you oh
yeah and so you guys roll in mm-hmm and
now now were you the first people to
roll in or the police roll in first well
so the bodies are always going to be
gone so the police are going to do the
wellness check and then the coroner's
going to come
to remove the actual body or whatever
that they can remove typically they're
going to try and remove like one large
piece so sometimes you know there's
still skin or depending on how long it's
still there really shoes maybe
well they weren't wearing them right but
uh you know and so if you died on the
second floor if you've been there for a
long time that stuff will all drip down
through the ceiling underneath and
then into the basement maybe so all that
flooring has to come out so the flooring
comes out your subfloor comes out if
it's affected like joists sometimes you
have to do some structural removal
all the way down to the concrete
basically
so is and is there like legalities where
if something dies in a place if a human
dies you have to do certain things to
the to the
building yeah so there there's really
stringent like processes that you have
to do so there's specific chemicals that
have to be used that have to meet these
certain regulations
um or standards and
so everything has to be removed and
there's a book called the s 500
that is a restoration book so that's
going to have like your processes like
if you had a question
um
you know you'd be able to
sorry no worries
no no
no no i'm not taking any calls right now
but um
yeah so there's a book of standards so
there's there's really
strict processes that have to be
followed so you can avoid liability you
know so like
you know on a water loss if you have bad
mold and someone gets sick and you
signed off that that building is dry
uh you can be you know either your
business or sometimes personally brought
up in like
court cases so you have to everything's
documented some liability yeah and on a
large like loss i'm doing a a hotel
right now in north dakota um
you know it's 40 44 affected rooms
and i'm going to submit probably 1100
pictures wow so and then processes
moisture readings all that stuff you
know right hours and hours and hours of
paperwork so you gotta yeah you so you
go in there and do a lot of paperwork
too it's not just you're out there
um
you know cleaning up the environment
yeah you guys are doing a lot of the
backlogging as well documentation yeah
there's a ton of documentation that goes
along with everything so take me on a on
a on a journey if you got you got called
in give me a take me into a story where
it was a
a mur or decease or something like that
you know uh
non-living human yeah yeah um
well you know i've done a bunch from
over the years but uh probably the worst
one i've ever done uh was in an
apartment building
and uh you know so we get the call
corners release the scene so
everything's out
and uh this fella met the wrong end of a
shotgun
okay and so it was a 12-gauge shotgun so
all those bbs went
through multiple walls and through
multiple apartments
so because those are contaminated and
carrying everything so you have to find
like where all those holes went so i
mean
when we got there you know so first
thing you know you're going to clean up
as much of the
let's call it raw material as you can so
you can avoid like
bug problems okay so you got to get up
all the hu all the living stuff whatever
could have been living or semi-living
the leftovers as much as you can yeah so
i mean you're scraping that floor off
you know you're using like a flat blade
shovel and scraping stuff off day old
bread baby you got to clean it yeah yeah
and then
yeah so then you're setting up ozone
machines uh
air filtration you're setting up an
environment so like if we're in this
room you need plastic over the doors and
and stuff so
you so that you're trying not to
cross-contaminate anything else okay so
you you tighten it up the scene mm-hmm
okay you kind of
get that kind of like a
plastic off the scene y'all use visqueen
fist queen you ever use it no bring up
this queen raleigh
there you go oh sure yeah yeah you can
barely see it because it's actually
see-through plastics yeah yeah just just
like that polly yeah we just call it
like polly and it comes with different
thicknesses yeah yeah i used to call it
bisque queen back in the day but
um okay so you guys you guys will kind
of cordon off the scene and then what so
then you're going to set up uh you need
to have air filtration
air scrubbers
and this guy had taken his life or he'd
been shot no he had taken his own life
yeah and so then you have to go through
and find you know where did those all
stop and did they exit the roof you know
and we ended up having to do some
patching on the roof too
wow so a guy took his own life and is
there still people in the building or no
yeah it was an apartment building and uh
it was real gnarly so then after you've
identified everything you know you're
making sure the roof's not gonna leak
and stuff because you don't want any
secondary damage yeah um then then it's
just all about
taking everything apart so every
affected stud needs to be taken out
replaced all the drywall that's affected
it's got to again be taken out okay yeah
and so what and who's still in the place
is is
did he have family or no so he was the
only one in that apartment but there was
other people in the rest of the
apartment building it's not like they
moved everyone out right i see
yeah this is an interesting guest um and
i'm letting you know that today's
episode is brought to you by ritual
yeah protein powders can be intimidating
but the fact is that we need protein
you know your body's made out of protein
so you have to continually have protein
it's not just about muscles
protein helps support bone health and
satiety
say t
rituals essential protein is is a
delicious plant-based protein powder
with three distinct formulas designed to
meet the body's changing protein
needs that's right
they have the
daily shake 18 plus
the daily shake 50 plus and the daily
shake pregnancy and post partum
yup with rituals one of a kind visible
supply chain you know the what how and
why of every labeled ingredient so you
know exactly what you're getting it's
made with a complete amino acid profile
ready to shake up your protein ritual
tpw listeners get 10 off during their
first three months at ritual.com
t-h-e-o
ritual even offers a money-back
guarantee if you're not a hundred
percent in love so that's beautiful
if you're not in love and get your money
back and that's rare
visit ritual rit ual.com
t-h-e-o today for 10 off your first
three months thank you
you know a lot of health brands are um
alienating customers
they pretend they're they're that their
thing is a cure-all or uh um will make
your life
irrepeccably happy
well mudwater values authenticity over
fake marketing
and makes room for the messiness of the
human experience
mud water it's a coffee alternative
with four adaptogenic mushrooms and
ayurvedic
herbs
and only one-seventh the caffeine of a
cup of coffee it's an alternative now
you get energy and focus without the
crash or anxiety
mud water is as versatile as your coffee
and you can add in different little um
dealies and this and that to
sweeten it or adjust it or do as you
wish
just like coffee
they also separately offer mud water
rest a caffeine free blend to promote a
state of calm so you can get the kind of
sleep
that will make you wake up and high-five
yourself
go to mud water slash theo and use code
theo to get 15 off your first purchase
that's m-u-d-w-t-r-dot-com
t-h-e-o and use code t-h-e-o for 15 off
all orders ship within the u.s and
canada
okay so yeah take me into a uh into a
scenario where you had to go where there
was a where there was um
yeah take me into one of like kind of
the gnarlier scenarios that you had
dealing with like a human corpse
yeah so the easily easily the only one
that's ever really bothered me the one
that really kept me up was uh
a guy unfortunately took his life in his
basement
with his family upstairs he had two kids
you know teenage
children and his wife were there okay
and they didn't leave
they
so the whole time that we were there
working
they stayed so we are carrying stuff in
the room in the basement
they were upstairs yeah and uh but no
you know and normally they they would
always move out
right you know until everything's
completed and put back together in this
case they they did not want to leave so
you roll up to the place
and who are you with is it just you do
you have a little buddy with you this
one was just me
um so i'll generally just go for like
i'll check it out and if i need labor
i'll call for it okay um but i i
generally don't ever ask anyone to do
these gnarly ones with me damn i'm just
doing satan's minion baby out there yeah
you know i'll have people but like i
never want i never like to ask other
people to do this kind of stuff because
it can really kind of weigh on you okay
so okay right no i can only fathom that
and we'll get we'll get into that a
little bit but so you get to this one
locale and what's going on so like i
said and generally i'm dealing either
with the police or the coroners
um
this is the only situation where i've
like met a family member at a
okay like a suicide particularly
sometimes if someone's died of natural
causes you know i'll meet a son or a
daughter or a wife or something like
that
but this one i knock on the door and
this lady answers it answers the door
and she was the homeowner so they were
still there like he's killed himself
yesterday and they're all still in the
house
um
and so you know i'm down working in the
basement and i'm carrying up boxes and
bags of you know contaminated stuff
past them wow so you're just bringing up
like basically stuff that has like human
matter on it yeah like you know oh it's
horrendous so he's like you're looking
did he did the man
yeah gun himself in the head
and so a lot of your head just kind of
goes wherever
yeah does your head go in one piece or
does it go in a bunch of pieces no and
it depends on the type of gun or the
caliber but typically it's just gonna
you know if you shot yourself with like
a hollow point
you'll like blow a hole out of the back
of your head but if it's a if it's like
just a normal handgun or something it's
actually a pretty clean hole normally oh
wow but um
yeah it's this was yeah so at the end
every day i had to tell you know she's
asking me questions and
and it's just like i you know you look
at her in the eye and saying it's like
oh we're going to be
finishing taking your husband out
tomorrow you know it's
crazy and did they come down and want to
do any prayers or did they want to like
spend any time pray was there
was it
did they like the husband you know it
didn't seem like they had a good
connection with the who knows i was
really trying not to talk to him oh you
were yeah it was that that really
bothered me yeah oh i can only fathom
man i mean that's a man
yeah i'm just trying to yeah i guess we
don't know all the circumstance but if a
man yet took his life as families right
there i can only imagine this how
and then or i just wonder if they're
looking at you like you're helpful or
like
who knows i have no idea yeah but that
man i still think about that one that
one was
tough
yeah and did the kids try to communicate
with you or anything there was no no i
mean they were obviously grieving but i
mean it was it was wild that they
wouldn't go to a hotel or stay with
family or something yeah at least headed
down fairfield inn and suites or a days
in um
you know and i love hampton and actually
but yeah i can't imagine if that
happened that i wouldn't want some space
or
maybe you want to be as close as you
know i don't know i don't know but that
was a unique circumstance
one and only time and hopefully the last
time that ever happened because it
really made it it really added what like
another yeah
yeah you know because you like i said
you get really desensitized to it and
and you know it's just like you're just
cleaning up a mess you know but when
they're there it's like i'm cleaning up
dad right yeah
right right
like our allen or whatever they got yeah
yeah
yeah harold or something yeah yeah it's
more i i can't imagine that
gosh i'd almost feel
bad in a way yeah yeah it really gave me
the heebie-jeebies
and so on a cleanup like that where do
you go for lunch on a day like that like
what is is there do you have like a are
there some days you go for different
lunches or but say if it's a you know do
you have a typical spot you like to go i
get a real problem with chipotle you do
yeah yeah i feel like i should buy stock
in there maybe they should give me stock
at this point oh you've been there a lot
a lot
yeah
well look i'm just saying if you know
what goes with cleaning up a a deceased
you know i guess it's chipotle yeah
yeah or a couple of beers you know yeah
and get through it yeah oh yeah god's
chipotle baby
surveys us
um
wow that's so fascinating what about
like living people do you do you come
into like trauma where the people are
still alive or is it all kind of post
life
uh well so trauma probably makes up sub
10 of what i do on a
weekly basis that's not all i do so okay
restoration on as a whole you meet a lot
of strange people um you know okay so
trauma is just dealing with the deceased
yeah okay so that is specified that is
trauma cleanup
somebody is deceased yeah and if you're
non-deceased this could be part of
restoration yep okay yeah so every so
restoration covers that it's a big
umbrella of a bunch of different stuff
but you know i've done some really
gnarly animal hoarders oh yeah really
like where the floor or walls are
rotting out because there's so much you
know animal urine that bootleg noah's
ark oh god i mean sometimes when they
got animal piss in there oh yeah oh dude
i'll tell you this so i stayed at my
buddy johnny's house one time right i'm
over there i don't know if anybody ever
stayed there except johnny and uh hit
one of his folks so they put me in the
guest bedroom one of the dogs had been
urinating in there for probably seven or
eight years right and i don't know if
anybody been in there there was like a
sewing machine
and like um somebody
like quilted like a little thing that
said like be back soon or something they
kind of had a sad vibe in there but
anyway i go in there the carpet had like
almost had a yellow dust in the air from
all the piss yeah it's called urea
crystals is it really yeah pull it up
raleigh
yeah
that yeah those uh urea crystals and i
know a lot of [ __ ] are buying these
these days and wearing around their neck
over there in venice beach
look at there you go look at that boy
get you a couple grams of that sell that
on the beach baby
that's that piss cane baby right there
son yeah urine dries in uh that that oh
and it's terrible and and they attract
so every time you get humidity they
attract or they kind of rehydrate so
every time it gets humid you just just
smell it oh that piss comes back
yeah well look uh because i remember
being in my buddy's place and i i would
breathe and sometimes i had to blow my
nose the air was so thick because i
would have to i would remember being
like oh my god something feels like it's
like my nose is and it would be i would
just be blowing animal piss right out of
my own nose yeah it's horrendous just
fascinating to be a part of yeah i gotta
i got a call
this is a few years ago now that the hoa
required like it was like a house you
know and uh the hoa had sent her
complaints because you could smell it
outside wow
and and i got there and i mean she
must have had
30 40 cats there
now when you roll up are the cats on the
outside or it's all in it's all inside
and and unfortunately i mean this lady
had some something going on upstairs
and the the other thing you run into a
lot is
nudity
i i i just something's not firing
upstairs you know okay so take me
through the cat lady let's walk through
that a little bit so i can just have an
experience of what that's like with you
you know you're walking up to the door
yeah do you know in advance it's cats do
you know it's generally just animalia so
what do they tell you we know that
there's animal issues okay so not a ton
of information
so i pull i i call her on the way there
and i'm like hey you know this is rob
i'm gonna be there about half an hour oh
and so i get there and i'm knocking on
the door and she is yelling through the
door who is it okay i'm like it's rob
and she's like i don't know any rob and
i was like i just talked to you 30
minutes ago oh yeah denial yeah and it's
just like okay and so she opens the door
no shirt on and she's like i just need
to go get dressed real quick why don't
you step in so she so no shirt tits out
just tits out older lady just a set of
swingers on her really and uh did you
feel like she's flirting no no no no no
i mean this lady was in her 70s she's
loose so her brain's a little bit loose
yeah something's not firing on all
ceilings okay and so i step inside and
soon and i can smell it outside i step
inside i mean it is so horrendous i mean
eyes are watering there's birds and dogs
and cats i mean it is crazy oh
everything's in there everything is in
there wow and birds too yeah i mean what
kind of birds was it
maybe a parrot or
wow parrots and cats something i think a
peridot will kill a cat will you bring
that up to riley
i'm sure i could get it
they're mean
there you go can a pair kill a cat most
parrots won't attack cats for the fun of
it
but may attack out of fear or
self-defense even if the cat isn't
actually trying to cause harm wow that's
wild so so my bad man so you're in there
you got the parrots the cats you got a
lot of animals oh yeah and are they just
kind of running around everywhere yeah i
mean they're just everywhere so she
comes back in a robe and she's like i
got three plates i needed to clean at
the time i was i was there i was there
for a carpet cleaning call okay so i get
out there and she walks me in and as
we're walking i mean the carpet is wet
not like damp wet like it is literally
squishing under my feet and it's just
like holy [ __ ] i mean it is terrible and
you can smell a pistol you have on a
face mask or not i should have i should
have i made a mistake but you're going
up straight in there you raw dog how
dark yeah damn boy and uh yeah they're
huffing seat piss baby just horrendous
just horrendous and so she walks me over
the landing of the stairs and as i'm
walking out of the land of the stairs
she is like standing between me and like
the exit and i like walk up and i'm
standing on the stairs and the stairs
are soft the floor is rotting
and she's like i just need to get this
cleaned up and i just like i i don't
think that this is like carpet cleaning
territory anymore like she's like well
how much do you think that's gonna cost
and i was like well i'm gonna need to
get bids
you know we need to get carpenters and
stuff out here and she's like well how
much do you think that's gonna be i was
like maybe ten thousand eleven thousand
off the top of my head and she doesn't
even blink she's like i thought i i
thought i had a coupon for 179 dollars
for three rooms and i was like
carpet cleaning is not gonna help this
yeah
and and so now it's like i'm starting to
panic because this lady is just yeah
she's like give me those weird crazy
eyes yeah she's gonna trade you you pcc
oh my god and and the the the piss is
you know two and a half feet it's
creeping up the wall it's soaking into
the walls you can see it yeah and who's
doing it do you know the cats are doing
it can it be also human piss
could have been
it could have been it wouldn't be the
first time i've had to clean up a
significant someone that's incontinent
unreal
yeah okay so you got it so now you guys
have to go in and what get all the
animals out who do you call them for
help oh well in that case she we did not
do anything she just wanted us
she just wanted the carpets cleaned wow
um i am
i am positive that she got moved out of
that yeah yeah i mean that that's that's
the situation where social services gets
involved
yeah the hoa
rder baby that's hoarder huh is that
order yeah that's a that's called an
animal hoarder
yeah and so is it a mental well is it
mentally unwell do you see what's caused
it is it loneliness did you do you get
any idea what the root cause of it is
it's some sort of mental disorder okay
yeah
and they want the cats and are they
enjoying the cats are they petting them
or is it more just
they
they're trying to have a little little
jungle do you get any idea what they're
trying to do
no idea it yeah like i said i mean it's
just it's compulsive
you just keep bringing them home and
they can't care for them you know
sometimes you know you find
in an in hoarder situations you know
you'll find cats or dogs that have been
dead for a long time and they don't even
realize they've been dead
you know you'll be clearing stuff out
and all of a sudden you come across a
little corpse
really yeah and nobody will say hey your
cat's dead and they're like oh
yeah i threw a ball and i didn't get it
or something yeah well you know they
don't have names for all the kids you
know oh man dude we had this lady when i
was growing up she used to give us a
dime right to go get her cats right this
older lady
so she said yeah i got like 30 cats you
know bring them in here to me i'll give
you a dime for each one y'all catch
well she only had three cats
but we'd let we go show her the cat get
that dime and then let that [ __ ] loose
and then go get it again
and we just kept running these three
cats until we had probably a buck 50.
and then go get us a little video we'd
do a video rental or sometime you get a
video and a pound of shrimp over there
they had a place called pat's video and
shrimp bring that up riley
pat's video and shrimp pat's video in
shrimp
covington louisiana
i don't know if you still got a video
store going on out there yeah oh that's
a good point yeah i just thought they
might have some old imagery yeah yeah
wow man so you really are kind of like a
do you get a feeling that you're like a
rescuer or that you ha does it start to
create any kind of feeling of like a
social or human responsibility in you or
does it just feel
like you are
when it when it's dealing with uh with
humans does it just feel like you are
kind of like a
does it feel janitorial does it get
human at all some of the feeling of it
no no never and i mean i joke about this
a lot with my buddies but i just never
say no
and it's just like all these jobs have
just escalated wow and and i just work
for myself like i don't have any
employees or anything i work as a
subcontractor for other companies
typically as like a project manager and
so i'm using their people so i mean i
just never say no
and you know so it's just the the jobs
over time have just gotten worse and
worse and worse and worse you know
like so like when companies don't have
anyone that feels comfortable doing like
a small restoration company they they
don't have anyone that maybe wants to do
trauma or something like that they'll
call me bobby cotton the unfazable bob
bobby cotton dude they call you bobby or
not
regularly
bobby kind of get often the unfazable
bobby cotton man and they call you in
and so tell me like an example of
something have you ever found anything
unique in a property you undid some
flooring or something and found a
treasure find a skeleton or something
not anything i wanted to find okay
yeah i mean like i said i found a lot of
a lot of small animals you know um
found like a significant amount of money
that like someone had left before and
hidden yeah yeah god i like that yeah so
what about some more like human take me
on you a call you get you go to a place
and there's a human there and you have
to interact with it with a human and
maybe uh
something outside of animalia maybe
well i got another hoarder call okay so
this is on christmas eva this year
and uh so we get the call early in the
morning it's a sewage cause that just
means there's different categories of
water losses so water clean water gray
water sewage okay um so this one was uh
sewage and so we get the call and i get
out there and i got one other guy coming
with me and so i get out there first and
i walk into the desk
and it's a condo building
and uh they're like hey i just want to
let you know that the source unit is up
on the like 10th floor or something he's
kind of a character okay he's like so
alarm bells are already going off
and do you keep a piece on you no never
yeah
um
so you know check it out i look around
you know a couple different floors and
so i got to go check to see the source
unit now so i knock on the door and it's
an old folks home and i knock on the
door and the guy answers the door he's
in a diaper wow so he's in a t-shirt and
a diaper and i was like and the smell
from in here is just horrendous and it's
a grown man definitely yep yep yeah
man's maybe 75 years old oh yeah and so
walk in
and i asked him like where's where's the
where where did it start from he's like
oh the toilet backed up okay it's like
okay and man has a diaper on man has a
diaper on does it seem like he's well
and he has a diaper on does it seem like
it's just hot it's a hot day or does it
seem like he's oh we'll get there okay
we'll get there so we walk in
and there's piles of newspaper piles of
mail and the floor is soaked
so again you're just squishing
and uh so walk in and he's gonna he's
like oh it's back here so i'm following
this man's diaper is
full
saggy really yeah he's so he's walking
me back there you think it's piss or
duty it is duty
and so he walks and this thing is
swinging no oh wow and so we're walking
past and we walk back into the back
bedroom and there's a batch on him a
pile of diapers okay sitting in this
water a pile of them two feet tall
and uh and everything these newspapers
are all sitting there so now he shows me
where it is and this toilet is just oh
so now i'm looking for a broken toilet
because i if you've ever backed up a
toilet it doesn't just keep flowing over
that's that batch of dirty diapers oh
yeah oh and so this this original
cornhole game i think it looks like the
the living conditions in here are
horrendous and so i look at the toilet
i'm looking for it to be broken okay
it's not broken
and i asked like well so what how did
all the water happen he's like well this
it plugged up at like 10 o'clock last
night
and
i was like well how did it flood
everything he's like oh i just kept
flushing it so for like six hours this
dude is just flushing this toilet over
and over and over again
and
like it's a
like a
video poker or something huh he's just
sitting there playing it yeah just over
and over again so and just winning just
just winning his own money just winning
his own just winning [ __ ] back and i
mean so it's right there so it's you so
it's a full it's a toilet and there's
duty in it oh oh everywhere it's covered
i mean it's just like somebody shotgun
blasted
duty all over everything oh man so we're
going and we
we are shoveling all this stuff into
bags because it's all sitting in all
this water everything's garbage i mean
we're talking years of newspaper years
of mail this guy just got piled up and
it's all and all the water kind of has a
little bit of feces in it
so so we finish everything out we cut
out all the carpet everything and the
last thing we got to do and my buddy's
there now and uh the last thing we got
to do is pick up these diapers so he's
holding a bag and he's like trying to do
it we're in full tivac suits you know so
we're in plastic suits respirators
everything
and he's standing he's like i can't do
it i'm like all right i'll try and i'm
staying there because we were like
arguing about who's going to do it and
you know so i go down and i reach for
the very first diaper
and i'm wearing gloves and i i go to
pick it up right in the middle like and
it's like a burritos oh and this man is
now naked from the
waist down watching us so
he has lost the diaper and he has told
us that he can't wear the pants
sometimes because he has to go to the
bathroom real fast no way so so would
the pants prevent him from doing it i
guess i don't know i don't know what it
is and you could see his wiener and oh
yeah right in the middle one-eyed willy
just hanging out and what style of
wiener was it was it like a
real old one really saggy yeah bring up
um
you know what they do have a chart song
people use sometimes i've seen uh bring
up a mushroom chart if you can riley a
mushroom if it's a pecker if it's a
petrini or whatever zoom in on that a
little if we can get some names off this
bad boy
because yeah
oh this is a poisonous mushroom chart no
it was in fact a poisonous mushroom
that's a good point huh
man that's not really one go back again
riley sorry that's two poisonous i think
let's just look at that let's look at it
one more hey go down a little um
i wish they had something had some names
on it okay go up
maybe go over to the left
move something so i can see something
yeah just move somewhere on there
uh are we to the left or not yeah okay
yeah hit on that one then let's see what
we got
oh that looks like those look like
realistic ones
yeah let me see on that
can you make that one big
zoom in on it there we go zoom in more
let's see if we can see some of the
names on there
the shaggy mane right there the f
that fly agari
what they got that honey cup what are we
looking at here you think
uh
rob if you had to look at one oh if you
go over the left there go to the left
uh like like something uh like that go
poor porcini oh damn okay yeah there you
go
damn he had that beat that ballpark
frank on him huh oh yeah okay so okay
yeah so this guy's just now completely
naked from the waist down he is donald
ducking it okay indeed do you have do
you feel the responsibility to stay in
there can you leave do you feel like the
guy is like
gonna attack or anything like that
nothing like that i i feel confident in
my ability to fend off a 75 year old man
okay
um so i pick up i go to pick up the very
first diapers now there's probably 75 of
these things we're going to pick up and
they're all soft and wet and because
it's soft and wet it has lost its
structural integrity so i go to pick it
up and my fingers just sink right into
it and it's oozing out and i'm just i've
got a strong stomach after doing this
for a long time
and it i'm i'm losing my lunch so i
i rip off my mask and i just like take
the one step over the toilet and i just
open this toilet it's just covered in
[ __ ] we didn't clean the toilet first
and i am projectile vomiting in this
toilet
and i look over to the guy my guy i'm
working with is standing there and he's
like oh and he tries to get his mask out
and he pukes straight into the mask and
he runs over to the other bathroom so
we're both just vomiting you can
straighten your mask that's like a frat
part of your heart so he just puked
straight into his mask yeah oh it's
terrible and she puked right into the
toilet that was already i'm trying not
to touch it oh it's horrible and so then
i look up and i'm on my hands and knees
on the throwing up in the store and i
look over the door again and this dude
is standing in the doorway so i'm on my
hands and knees i'm right looking this
dude's willy right in the eye and he
started jerking off no
no no no he's just standing there
watching he started jerking no
he's the ryan sandberg of creepy [ __ ] he
started doing that unfazed like this is
a cycle then baby yeah this is this is
just like a normal tuesday afternoon for
this guy
just watching
just and do you think loki he he had
people come all the time and created
this kind of scenario i have no idea i
mean it was just it was that's one of
the worst ones i've ever done and so how
does that scenario get from right there
to actual some sort of solution well i
mean so
everything has to be taken out so like
all the flooring all the carpet all that
concrete needs to get cleaned
um and then you know you just rebuild it
so all that drywall that gets cut out
you know you just got to replace it
repaint it new carpeting so at some
point you guys left that premise and it
was nice again and you put the man back
in there
yeah wow
yep man
that blows my mind
yeah that was terrible and how much what
how much uh are you wearing like are you
what kind of suit you were you like an
astronaut or are you like uh well so
that's so like the ones the ones that
you pump air into so like if you're
dealing with something like really
hazardous it's called a positive air
suit okay um
uh you know if you're doing like
somebody
dropped a vial or something of some
dangerous disease i mean i've i've done
that before but um
we're wearing what's called a tyvek suit
so it's got boots it's just one
continuous suit with a hood on it and
then a respirator
and a set of rubber gloves wow almost
like a walter white wears kind of yeah
just like that that is a tyvek suit
that's what those are
so do meth heads ever roll up to you
while you're going in and out of the
building trying to holler like is there
ever that kind of vibe where people
think you're making drugs no no nothing
like that but you know it tends to
attract attention yeah you know you're
carrying boxes out or bags out in a full
tyveks who people want to know what
you're doing yeah yeah bet i'm sure you
get a lot of onlookers or people that
are stopping you you wanting a curious
folk
oh yeah and you never tell them anything
really yeah because you don't like the
the property owner doesn't want people
to know that someone's died or that
there's been a loss or even some uh even
some customers like big customers
they've got like stealth protocols they
don't want any company vehicles parked
outside they don't want you to wear
anything that says a logo on it or
anything
they don't want people to know that
something's happened
yeah because i guess people don't want
to mess up their resale value or get a
lot maybe uh somebody
or if it's a product if they're making
you know honey baked hams or something
and somebody loses a limb they don't
want people saying oh they got
limbs in the ham or whatever you know
like you know people don't anyone
claiming that there's a fingernail in
their ham you know yeah yeah yeah they
don't want people yeah they don't want
people kind of uh i guess
just ruining their business you know
that they work so hard for wow
hair loss scares people sometimes
you wake up and you one of your side
burns is on your pillow or your mustache
is on your wife's back
or somebody
that's scary that's hair loss
and two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35 that's true
keeps
is the one who can help you
they offer affordable stress-free ways
to keep your hair
the treatment plans
start at just 10 bucks a month
and keeps offers generic versions of the
two fda approved medic medications
to prevent hair loss i'm on the generics
to be honest
that's where i am on that cheap skate
24 7 care and support keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals
reality you can do it
they have everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door with
discreet packaging and proven results
remember prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com
slash t-h-e-o to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash theo to get your first month free
keeps.com slash theo
you know if you've ever listened to this
podcast you know that sometimes um
life can be overwhelming i've talked a
lot about that and
i get caught in that space myself a lot
where even if my life isn't overwhelming
it feels overwhelming that's a space i
get in as well well many people are
burned out without even knowing it
and that was me
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped
detached fatigue and more
we associate burnout with work but
that's not the only cause
a lot of our lives can make us feel
burnt out
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
that's right better help is customized
online therapy they offer video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to
you know it's therapy and and bites you
can handle and we all need um
we need our therapy to meet us where we
are
that's sometimes what turns people off
about therapy is they're just afraid
they're afraid it's going to be
overwhelming too much
this past weekend listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
theo that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash t-h-e-o
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy and can be met and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
that's betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
so
are there jobs that you won't do i know
you said you'll do anything has there
been a job that you said you know what
there there's been things i've regretted
taking okay yeah um you know when you're
wading through you know four feet of
sewage and like chest waiters
yeah there's been horrendous ones
and when you're doing that do you feel
like god is with you or you feel like
you strayed from the pack do you feel
any human response like a personal like
okay maybe i'm making some choices that
are kind of wild do you do you think
like that you're kind of like the bear
grylls of like of like
you know uh
duty and and and
death
well um
i feel like i should have finished high
school yeah
did you finish no
no never did i've been i've been joking
about getting my ged for years but uh
you know i i've got my life together
real well and i always joke that you
know people with geds
uh you know they always used to say that
you know if you only have a high school
diploma or a ged you make a million
dollars less than if you went to college
and i was like well i don't want to do
that then yeah you know i don't want to
oh you don't want to go why go get that
if i'm going to guarantee make a million
less yeah exactly
never hear anything about people that
don't finish high school dude well
that's freaking interesting man because
you really have kind of it seems like
carved out your own space um yeah take
me on a little bit of a journey of like
what are some of the calls that you you
like you you wish you hadn't done is
there any other one oh there where are
you walking sorry go ahead well i mean
the one i was just telling you about uh
there was a a pump station so in the
where i live at there's a river the
mississippi or the minnesota river and
they pump sewage to a facility on the
other side of the river okay so there's
a gigantic pipe that for whatever reason
got plugged up and so this pump is
running and there is one cul-de-sac
before it goes across the river so
there's only like six seven houses on it
that's on the other side of the pump so
everyone else is on you know the this
side of the pump then the pump pushes
across and there's one more spot where
it goes in okay so it plugged somewhere
under the river so this pump a gigantic
pump is pumping
and because it got blocked up it ended
up forcing the sewage into those houses
so when i talked to the guy that lived
there he said they were sitting around
in the house and then all of a sudden
there was like a noise that came from
like the sink and it was like shooting
up like a fountain out of everywhere out
of the toilets out of the
sink set it everywhere of dirty water uh
yeah sewage yeah oh and and it ended up
like those chocolate things they have so
i'm at a wedding yeah
yeah chocolate fountain of goodness
um and so it was like shooting up and
hitting the ceilings and like spraying
out and then ended up filling up this
guy's basement
oh so we got big you know pumper trucks
and uh so they're taking it away and so
i'm in chest waders holding this hose
like sucking stuff up and it keeps
getting plugged from stuff in there so
i'm i'm in a tyvek suit and chest
waiters so the hose keeps getting yeah
so like i'm i'm down there like holding
it because if you just let it go it'll
get stuck to stuff and i mean oh god it
was terrible
and uh
yeah so i'm wading through sewage like
six feet of sewage
yeah it was pretty awful and do you have
any other little henchmen that roll with
you kind of or you said it's kind of you
roll in and then work with like do you
then like subcontract other guys to help
you how does that kind of go yeah so
like i said i generally
i never work under my own contract so
it's like if you if something happened
here yeah and i showed up and you called
whatever restoration company you'd never
know that i worked for a different
company
or that i'm self-employed because i just
typically manage those projects okay um
but i normally show up on the data loss
and stabilize the situation then there's
a lot of clean up that has to happen
demo drying whatever that needs to be
um so i'll typically use either their
labor or their subcontract labor
so i don't typically ever hire anyone
personally i'm using their resources
do you notice when it comes to more of
the people that have some real issues
right is it more men or women do you
notice like do you have any clue where
the mental unwellness comes from is
there do you start to get any
grasp on what could have happened to
some of these folks
yeah i i really don't know if it's like
a trauma thing or if it's uh
you know just something's never quite
been right upstairs or something i i
really don't know but uh the the common
the the common thing is
it seems like people
like start like they just can't take
care of themselves and when they don't
have like the resources or the family to
to help them everything just spirals out
of control
and and i mean uh just the the living
situations that people are in i mean we
really need better mental health
something around there but uh yeah we
need i mean i need everybody's we're all
trying to get it um
what about take me on another journey
something like uh with some of these
hoarders what are some other things that
you see people hoarding because you had
the man with the duty diapers and
um
what are some other things that people
keep that you notice
it tends to be like dated stuff so i
mean a lot of times it's
like just knickknacks or something like
that it's like they go to the garage
sale and buy the whole garage sale it
feels like um otherwise it's like i said
dated stuff so newspapers are really big
mail is huge and i mean it's like yeah
sometimes like rooms full of newspapers
you know for these older folks and
you'll find newspapers from the 80s wow
is it pretty cool some of them yeah i've
definitely flipped through some of those
newspapers it's been kind of neat and
what about any pornography you notice
anybody hoarding that kind of stuff or
not really yeah i mean you do find you
do find weird stuff uh you know i've
definitely found plenty of
like playboys and stuff like that
another thing i've noticed is men hoard
sex toys really yeah i've definitely run
into that a couple of times i mean we're
talking
200 dildos or something wow really and
is it gay men or straight men do you get
any idea if it's one of the other
i don't know yeah i'm not sure but
something phallic they want to have that
that
deal that's a weird one sex dolls
sometimes sex dolls as well yeah yeah
like the big ones like that i've i
forget what they're called and what do
you mean like bbw like kind of thicker
ones are you talking about like it's uh
no it's like a full-sized person they're
like a real doll or something like that
oh i see what you're saying and what are
they made of they're probably made out
of uh
it feels like skin
oh it does damn and so you've been in a
place where guys had a couple sex dolls
in there mm-hmm damn
another weird thing is when that movie
came out um
50 shades of grey
a ton of people started getting like red
rooms
and it's like a sex dungeony thing and
and a lot of people kind of got off on
like showing you that and it's like oh
sorry i forgot to shut this door
oh you mean if you go to a place yeah
people will have that just in their
house yeah they'll like leave it open on
for on purpose like they get excited
from you seeing that or like stumbling
into it have you had a lot of like uh is
there ever been in a place where
somebody's trying to get you in there
just to attract you or something or do
sexual or something like that
no uh like i said i do some carpet
cleaning too i use it used to be really
weird so i'd clean a lot of bars eat you
up at bar clothes
and i oh my god people to ask me oh what
are you can i help you over close oh i'm
here to clean the carpets i i must have
had
200 women say oh i hope you're here to
clean my carpets really oh yeah it's
terrible beating joke so you think you
could have probably had sex with them
though or at least tried to engage if
they wanted we could have engaged on
that yeah but yeah that was just a weird
thing it happened all the time like i'm
here to work yeah and it's like i'm sure
you're there's plenty of men here at
this bar for you to talk to but like i'm
this new person coming in at bar close
time i don't know i could see that the
worker comes in i'm here to clean the
carpets it's also such like a
you know it's almost a pickup line that
a guy at the bar would be using yeah
yeah and ah it was just it was so
bizarre i don't i don't know what that
was about either
and what about like urine do people keep
urine as well i know you've had a lot of
the uh yeah people keep jars of urine
that's not
that's happened more than once where
i've run into somebody who's got
like shelves and jars of urine yeah yes
what is that i don't people just have
like a fixation with like bodily fluids
yeah i wonder if they don't want to let
part of themselves go or they
because it's fascinating because a lot
of college people do it too a lot of
dudes will pee in a jug or something
they don't want to take it to the
because it's laziness yeah yeah i think
anyway um
but yeah i always wonder why do people
keep so much piss by them some folks oh
yeah i mean and it'll just be like jars
and jars and jars like small jars like a
baby jaw as well
oh okay mason jar really yeah just right
off a god still baby that freaking uh
kidney i mean that's happened at least
three times damn you run across some
good piss out there ah yeah
it is an experience oh i bet man it's
crazy enough to even see somebody peeing
in the bathroom really closer
you know but to see them standing there
with a couple jars of their own piss i
feel like seems
you know we've really lost that
experience since we're getting rid of
all those troughs at like the stadiums
so yeah they're not anywhere anymore oh
that team pissing yeah yeah where you
really experience another man pissing
right yeah yeah you're right there yeah
the craziest part is when you his arm is
touching your arm you can kind of feel
the vibration if he's really got a
[ __ ] you know if he's really doing
really connecting with strangers yeah
yeah you can really feel like how each
other's kind of flowing it's almost like
a little go-kart race kind of i feel
like we're losing our community based on
you know
everybody wants to piss on their own
separate space in the future they're
just going to give you a jar when you
walk into a jets game you're going to
have to you know
keep it to yourself
yeah take me down another road there
take me down uh yeah so i was in north
dakota for another job on saturday so
i'm sleeping in this this you know motel
and so i wake up
and i'm sleeping with another guy in a
room and he's like it's wet and i was
like what do you mean it's wet and he's
like the floor is wet
and and i i swung my feet after bed and
i put my feet down into puddles
and i was like you've got to be kidding
me like it's chasing us and i was like
did i fall asleep on a job site i'm
having a nightmare right now you know
and so i walk out of the hallway and
there's an inch of water in this entire
floor oh and i was like you've got to be
kidding me right and so i i jokingly
text one of the contractors at work for
he's like hey i found you a job and he's
like what's going on i was like oh you
know i fell asleep at the motel and it's
flooded you know
and uh so and i'm just kind of joking
with him about it like someone local
take care of this you know and so we me
and this other guy hop out in the truck
and we're gonna go we're gonna go out to
breakfast you know
and so as we're pulling out i see a
restoration company pulling in so i like
hop out of the truck i'm like i'm gonna
go talk to that guy real quick
and uh so i go and i talk to this guy
and i'm not gonna say the company name
but i was like i'm in town of this
restoration company he's like you're
kidding i was like no he's like will you
walk through this job with me i was like
yeah sure and so we go and we walk
through the job and the guy's like oh i
just i don't think i've got the
resources to do this right now it's all
flooding in grand forks right now
and he's like is this something you
think you can do
i was like really it was like yeah i was
like okay so i call that contractor back
that i
was i'm like hey we're gonna do this job
up here and it's gonna be a six figure
job wow and he's like and i'm like this
is why i'm your favorite subcontractor i
bring my own work
and so but we had to get equipment all
shipped up from iowa and generators all
up there oh yeah and you know my guy at
sunbelt rentals really pulled through
um yeah it's a rental company and what
kind of stuff do they rent for folks
everything you can rent a lawn mower
from them or you can rent a generator
big enough to power a skyscraper i mean
you can they rent everything forklifts
bobcats whatever sunbelt rentals is the
company yeah shout out to rick what's up
rick damn baby damn rick is usually
somebody else rick can go either way
i met some real dicey ricks and i met
some real quality wrecks yeah that's
where i'm going back after this though
really oh you're going back to
north dakota i got to finish that job up
and then i'm down to phoenix for a job
and so what's is it hard to keep a
personal life do you have a wife or
children no i got two roommates to take
care of my house wow
yeah so do you uh do you feel like you
could stay in restoration forever uh
does it wear on you as a human after a
while or at a certain point it's just
kind of
yeah i mean i i definitely can't do this
forever i mean the hours i work
sometimes i mean it's not uncommon to
throw in a hundred hours in a week
um
so i mean i've gotta like have a
retirement strategy i'm putting money
together by real estate right now yeah
um that's kind of my exit strategy to
start buying apartment buildings and
then once i've got enough income from
that i'll just manage those wow
and i guess you get so much recon and
research because you're in and out of
them all the time i know what to do yeah
you know how not to get screwed on
insurance
has it been hard to uh date during that
with that type of a lifestyle or do you
just kind of make you just i mean has it
been hard have a serious relationship
yeah yeah yeah it's definitely hard you
know i was like i don't know i'm on a
i'm on those those apps a little bit and
you know i've met some girls and then
you know it ends up not working out you
know i'm gone a lot i'm working a lot
you know so
you think some women would like that
kind of a man that's on you know you
know here you know he he's here and then
he's there you know yeah yeah
and and i mean the money's great in this
industry but yeah there's no personal
life so it's like we can go on vacation
and really ball out of control but he's
like i'm not going to be home every
weekend or at the end of the night every
night you know
well shoot if we if some ladies watch
this man we'll have to have him chime in
if you
ladies want to chat with rob cotton and
uh
you want them to come over and and
restore something you know clean your
carpets there you go
yeah you could definitely do that dude
um
yeah i had a
a question i'm thinking of is how do you
think that you could hide a body do you
learn anything from this type of stuff
do you think i am positive that i could
make a body disappear wow
yeah
i
yeah it's something that's doable yeah
yeah and what gives you that knowledge
just like doing it like how you clean up
a body like i mean you can just
yeah i mean
yeah i mean just like doing it you know
it's like if you can clean
blood and guts off of walls or a floor
you can
just clean them the same way
if you actually took someone's life yeah
i mean not that i ever would obviously
but i think that the actual dis like the
actual
like logistics of
making a body disappear i think is
pretty easy and pretty practical but uh
obviously it's it's the making someone
disappear
yeah that's the difficult part right
do you ever like look at a corner or
something like that who comes in before
you
on a human trauma site and think like
man i wish that that like do you ever
want to get into that line of work is
there anything about
it that makes you think that you kind of
moved a little further up the food chain
kind of of death
no no i mean i like i said i'll just i
just never say no so i mean to me work
is work i have no real
interest in restoration really i if i
was someone offered me five more dollars
an hour to dig ditches i would dig
ditches right so to me it's just about
the compensation i can't think of a
a different industry with my set of you
know circumstances or qualifications
that i could make more money doing right
um
what yeah what can a restorator make if
they have a good business going
well i mean
as a company i mean i think one person
like with no employees if you were just
subbing everything out you could
probably do seven figures a year wow um
that's if you really base it well and do
large loss restoration because a ton of
it is just equipment
and you know if you've got good demo
companies and stuff like that to do like
your actual flood cuts or anything else
like that i i think practically one
person could probably clear seven or
seven hundred
a million dollars a year
and how far
how far away can you smell piss from you
think honestly
i like i
i can
it really bothers me when i like walk
into a house because i'm so dialed into
like that
that ammonia smell a long ways away
a long ways away like like if your dog
goes outside into the backyard and
you're like i can like i feel like when
i walk into a yard i can tell if a dog
lives in that house wow
that's a skill man
yeah that's the skill to be able to
smell piss from so how many feet would
you say
i don't know uh
20 i don't know
20 feet 20 is not that far
i mean it's it's a pretty good distance
smell of piss but
yeah i guess that's true actually my bad
yeah that is true my bad man um yeah
yeah i guess i was hoping for i guess
part of me honestly was hoping for more
it's crazy quarter mile i don't know
i was like oh yeah he could snout a
batch of freaking
body sauce at a quarter mile um
do you think there's a time of year when
more trauma happens that you notice more
human trauma is there is there winter
time really yeah like especially around
the holidays that's when i get the most
suicide calls for sure
i wonder what that is you think i mean i
guess that's kind of a known thing that
people take their life around the
holidays maybe they're lonesome or yeah
i think it's just like you know people
are depressed and you know they're not
happy with like their famous family
situation or whatever
and if people doing suicide do they do
more do you ever see any rope suicide
still or is it all gun work
generally i'm only going to get calls
for gun stuff because there's not
generally a lot of cleanup if you hang
yourself okay
yeah and it's kind of crazy i mean this
is kind of dark but it's really
inconsiderate to kill yourself with a
gun in in a house you know because like
now someone's gotta deal with all that
yeah yeah yeah people don't think about
that you know people just think about
themselves when they're killing
themselves you know unfortunately and
uh which is part of the issue anyway why
you know they're just kind of stuck in
their own head and what's in in their
own pain
um
what about birds and bird [ __ ] you
running any things like that like
extensive because i've seen bert like
dude i remember one time i parked over
by i guess i was going into a
sava center or something or uh
it could have been
uh what's that place called um
where my folks like to go all the time
rouses
so it could have been a rouses market
but anyway i parked dude i swear to god
i was in there probably 16 minutes i
came out and birds had
completely [ __ ] up my vehicle
do you get a lot of stuff like that is
it feces i have never gotten a call for
a bird issue really never not at once
so i don't know if you can just like
scrape it off or something and you know
you don't ever need like professional
intervention
but i guess i'm thinking in a business
if birds have been like sneaking up in
an area and defecating for so long oh
yeah i don't know
chandelier falls in or something you
know it's like or you know a ceiling
come in you ever see the birds at like
home depot
yeah
how do where's all that [ __ ] go i've
never seen a bird [ __ ] in home depot
that's a good point there's lots of
birds maybe they have a different level
of respect for the place i don't know
that's a good question actually a good
guest yeah yeah that is a good guest
what do you enjoy doing on your personal
time brother i've really gotten into
raves lately really i really like edm
music okay yeah i'm looking forward i'm
i'm planning on going to uh edc which is
a big music festival nice that's gonna
be good and when y'all do like a lot of
people you do you get into some of the
drug culture the pill culture it's kind
of popular yeah yeah you'll get out
there and have fun oh yeah have a good
time
have you ever had any drug experiences
we had to call 9-1-1 on yourself never
i uh although
i i almost have yeah i mean chet i i've
gotten myself into trouble with too many
like edibles oh oh my god
you know you're you're contemplating
life oh yeah when you start i can't
believe i got a call for that hey we got
a guy over here who's just had too many
edibles
that happens a lot yeah i had a buddy in
my fantasy football league it was the
night before the draft he ate like a
little bit of an edible up in uh toronto
and next thing you know he was just
walking in a circle for about an hour
and a half in his room drinking orange
juice and milk
not doing well dude those things sneak
up on you yeah holy [ __ ] and that's not
fun i don't think doing that having
those beverages and just keep moving
like that
you know to me that's not a party
no no uh who do you like rufus to seoul
do you like stuff like that or do you
like like are you getting into some like
real uh nordic kind of german trance
stuff or what are you into no no i mean
definitely my favorite for sure is timmy
trumpet he is spectacular live izzy can
you pull him up there riley
timmy trump and it's a man
yeah mm-hmm
yeah he gets up on stage with like uh an
actual like trumpeter trombone mm-hmm
and i mean yeah that's him right there
okay yeah he is spectacular like uh
i'm seeing steve aoki in minneapolis in
a couple of a couple of this
that's fire yeah it's going to be a good
time
nice man and uh so you just kind of
travel around and do this this is what
you do
will you travel how many different
places will you go in a year
um
i don't know i mean that nothing too
crazy i generally stay in the midwest um
this this one is like the first one i've
done in arizona um i used to before this
before i did this i uh
i i
built and like maintained water towers
that was a lot of traveling oh really
you mean like in towns that have water
towers smaller towns
yeah and then transmission towers and
television towers like
changing light bulbs that was like
four cities a week that was like a
traveling comedian that's like that much
climb up those towers
wow
yeah so what's that like take me through
a water tower so a water tower like in a
small town or i get does it matter small
town or big city does it um i only
worked in small towns i mean obviously
they have them in large towns but you
know it was a lot of times
they would like just kind of put them on
a hill and it wasn't even really a water
tower just like a big tank on a hill
okay um and it's full of water though
and the reason for it it creates the
pressure that's how so like the reason
the water tower is up in the air is
because that's what provides the
pressure to your house okay uh it's not
like there's a pump or anything the pump
pumps it up in the air
and then it's just gravity is how you've
got your
like your pressure your tap
so a lot of people don't realize that if
there were no water tower in their town
they wouldn't have any water pressure
is that the same in cities and in
smaller towns well if you're that small
of a town you might have a well and then
you'd have a pump but if you've got like
city water yeah that's how that works
wow
interesting
so
even the water here you think yeah it's
probably because there's a water there's
a water tower in the area yeah okay and
so a larger place will they have more
water towers per population or yeah and
then when you get into a big enough town
like in like new york city or whatever
the water towers that provide the uh
the water towers are on top of the
buildings
it's like those tanks are on top of the
building yeah that's the provides the
water to that
building oh i see so though it'll even
get more localized to the actual
building where you get that little tank
up top that top tank dang
and so take me through that so you get
to a small town you roll up on a water
tower and there's a lot of bees and
stuff i bet huh yeah there's bees and
then the wind is what really kills you
um
it's really not that bad because i
worked on a service cruise so we didn't
generally build them okay um so a lot of
it was just like
doing inspections and and i would i
didn't do the inspections i was just
like support
um
or changing light bulbs you know you
know those those red blinking light
bulbs on tall structures there's heavy
fines if those go out oh really
so who finds the people
who who would find a town oh oh i mean i
wasn't in sales i mean there was
full-time sales guys they would right
but who finds say if the water tower or
light goes out
who gets fined for it oh the whoever
owns that structure so like if it's a
water tower it would be the city and
that's okay fines from the faa oh wow
like if you don't have functional lights
um transmission towers are gonna be
owned by like the radio station and the
television station so once you get up to
the actual tower you get is there
usually like a platform around the base
of the actual water bowl or bulb yeah uh
so it depends but uh generally yes
there's like a walkway okay uh on the
top and on around the like outside
um and then it's just a stick ladder up
wow
and what kit how do you get onto the top
cause it usually rounds up bring up a
water tower
brother
which what kind are we talking about
here um so generally i worked on those
top ones
okay um where it's like a metal tank
there you go let's link on one of those
there riley
yeah so there's gonna be a walkway and
then there's a there's two walkways
there okay and then there's a ladder
between them and then there's generally
an access panel on the top
can you largent up that
yeah so that one doesn't have the second
that one doesn't have the second walkway
but there's going to be a ladder on that
tank so there's a ladder that goes up
there and then there's a second ladder
that'll take you from the platform to
the top okay and then if you zoom way in
on that picture up at the very tip top
that should be an access panel right
there i see yeah
and when you get can you get into the
water yeah so when they do the
inspections they actually scuba dive in
the tank you would have to do that well
i didn't but yeah someone on the crew
would yeah and it's a licensed scuba
person wow
so somebody goes in there and what are
they looking for they're looking for
corrosion generally okay uh corrosion
any
like foreign materials but yeah
generally it's just an inspection on the
welds or the bolts make sure that it's
not
corroding okay so somebody goes in there
and inspects it and you guys ever find
anything in those things um not really i
mean sometimes it would be like
something that got pumped up like some
debris or a stick but almost never but
nothing like the level of stuff you're
finding now no no
the the transmission towers were worse
you know the transmission towers you
know there'd be 1100 1500
i think the tallest one in the united
states is in north dakota
um and that one's like not uh i might be
speaking at a turn but it's like
2050 feet oh feet up in the air yeah so
these you're not at a ton of risk up
there for like well you said wind is a
little bit issue when you're on these
water towers if it's a windy space then
you you yeah you got to really do you
kind of like uh
attach yourself as you're going up yeah
like a carabiner or something yeah you
you're you want to try and keep like a
hundred percent connection so like
you've got a
a harness on and then it's got a y hook
onto it and then that y hook so you hook
one up and then you climb a little bit
you hook the other one up so that you're
always connected even when you're moving
it yeah like le clerk like that boiler
clerk have you seen in the alpinist no i
haven't oh man it's good
um
and so when you get to the transmission
towers that's even that's way up there
and what is that
transmission tower raleigh yeah look up
television tower
television transmission tower yeah so
the taller your um
like antenna is or your broadcast pole
the less power it takes to go further
so if you get that you go up there yeah
no
what damn y'all up there huh and can you
hear television when you're up there no
no you can't hear any of that but a lot
of times i have cell phone towers or
like cell phone antennas on there you
got to be careful about that because
normally they'll only want to shut off
one side so you get a climb on one side
um
and if you accidentally climb in front
of one of those
like cell phone transmitters you'll get
a sunburn through your clothes yeah
because they work on microwaves i think
it's like just for like a second you
like you go in front of it because
they're so high powered you you're like
microwaving yourself no way so you would
like take your shirt off your sun burned
from just walking through the pathway if
you stayed in the path could you die
i'm sure you could i mean i would
probably take a while but it'd be a
crummy way to go and what's going
through you just all the calls and
everything all the information yeah what
yeah all that stuff yeah so that was
pretty nutty
they find you and you just have a nike
advertisement on your chest
you just have something yeah for butcher
box
wow bro that's bananas yeah that was
terrible
dude you've done some pretty unique jobs
man
just don't say no
wow and is that a model yours overall in
your life kind of a little bit
yeah i really do try um you know it's
like you know that's that's the only way
that i feel like i've been able to like
maintain like a um
like my personal life is just like i'll
work like a long time
and you know it's like well my friends
are going to a show or something like
that and so we'll go out and go to the
show show's done at like 1 30 and then
i'll go back to work sometimes yeah i
mean that's happened
you know but it's like if i don't just
do it then it's like you're just not
gonna have a personal life and it's yeah
it's the same thing and i was like when
you work like a lot of times i work
seven days a week you know it's like i
still want to go out to brunch and stuff
like that you know and even if you're
tired or whatever it is like but if you
don't like work to maintain it
it'll just go away you know
i love that man yeah cause i find
sometimes i i'll get too caught up in
what i'm thinking or feeling instead of
just staying busy with my work you know
yeah and a lot of times just staying
busy will keep you out of like
you know i'll get caught up in like
self-pity or just thinking about myself
too much it's like i guess the busier
you stay it really does just kind of
keep things moving yeah yeah and it's
like i've tried a lot of stuff i'm
always down to try stuff i mean it's
crazy that i'm here right now yeah i was
like yeah this is crazy man it's awesome
dude it's so fascinating to hear
what goes on who does this kind of stuff
because a lot of times we think that
things just get done somehow yeah you
know it's like oh that just gets done
yeah
but to think that somebody actually
comes and
and takes care of certain things
yeah it's interesting man because a lot
of us would never know what that's like
well it's like my next step what i
really want to get into is i'm working
on getting into large loss so like you
know million dollar projects and stuff
like that but i really want to do cat
work and that's like the hurricanes and
stuff so i mean like when there's
the hurricanes rolling through louisiana
someone's got to clean up all that stuff
i want to oh yeah my buddy giddy does
that and i think my buddy tully does
that from growing up they travel around
if there's a big hurricane or storm and
they do
i guess loss but that might be insurance
loss or something like that that might
be an insurance adjuster but you want to
get in there and really do the uh i want
to do the work yeah you want to do the
work yeah like i got a good buddy of
mine um
uh that they were down in texas for that
real bad freeze-up
and so like there was apartment
buildings that the every water pipe
burst and so i mean you're talking about
an apartment building it's got three 400
units in it and every single one's wet
and molding
and all that stuff's got to get gutted
like that's what i really want to do is
i want to do like the real large lost
stuff
wow and what's fascinating about i mean
i guess obviously it's a higher paying
job yeah and i mean it's just like the
idea of like doing the larger jobs where
it's like i've got one job for like the
next month instead of like the traveling
around all the time and the middle of
the night calls and stuff like that is i
i'd really like that i think
and how uh what do your folks think of
your work um
it's it's kind of funny so
uh my father just passed away
but
yeah thank you what happened with him a
cancer oh it just ate him alive
yeah it was saint patrick's day this
year no way
oh man was he pretty pretty pretty
pretty neat guy oh super cool i mean he
he's got a really crazy life story too
and family and everything wow um but so
when i was in high school and i was
really kind of [ __ ] things up um
he pulled me aside one day and he says
you know there's only three ways you can
be successful in this world you can do
things better than anyone else can do it
you can do something no one else can do
or you can do things that no one else
wants to do
and i was like that's what i'm gonna and
that was not how he meant that but uh
you know
[Laughter]
that's a really fast it's a really good
square way to kind of communicate with
your child yeah these are sort of the
options because it sounds very like okay
that
that makes real clear sense yeah
yeah i mean he was a well-spoken dude he
was an aircraft mechanic and my mother's
a therapist
and they meet each other at
through a
through a fedex driver oh damn yeah
that's that's a yeah so the my mom was
working at her mother's business and
their fedex driver was my dad's friend
okay and so you know he's meeting this
pretty girl at the fedex thing he's like
you gotta meet a friend of mine yeah and
so literally the fedex driver set them
up they were married for almost 30 years
that's delivery baby that's dang
yeah dude and look fedex i've always
thought first of all obviously they're
doing great things for people i don't
think amazon's really making love like
that but fedex man they should do
airline
because there's been times where i've
mailed a package somewhere and then i
tried to fly this commercial airline and
you i quit they're like we have a
something the flight's delayed or
whatever yeah but the package isn't that
thing goes out every time yeah if it
doesn't get there in a day they'll
refund you dude if fedex did an airline
i would be all over that like a
commercial airline it'd be so sick
yeah um well i bet your dad was really
proud of then how you became just so uh
so much your own ingenuity you know and
just taking control of your own destiny
yeah i mean there
he definitely shared with me that uh you
know what because i moved out you know
and i just dropped out of school i moved
out of the house yeah those are like
warning signs to a parent yeah they were
like oh we really weren't thinking that
this was going to work out you know
well made it work somehow do you think
there's any way to avoid trauma in the
world we've just finished with this
question like i said man i just think
that there's got to be better mental
health something i don't i don't know
the solution i don't pretend to know the
solution but
just like more care for people that
can't get care of themselves yeah you
ever roll up with anybody and they're in
a costume or something like that they're
dressed like a uh
you know they got a crown on or anything
like no nothing nothing crazy like that
but uh like i said i deal with some
people that uh
maybe not firing on all cylinders oh
yeah and uh
nudity is the
is the thing that happens a lot like
that's the first thing you know yeah if
somebody's new you kind of yeah if
you're if you're answering your door and
you're naked there's something not going
on right yeah there's a glitch there's a
little glitch in the system do we had a
guy buzz he used to he used to poop in
this va he had like a vas in this town
or vase or vaz
and uh
in his house and he would tell us go
look in the vas right and we'd be
pooping there
and we'd always be like there's not
still going to be maybe like a year or
two later dude and every time there was
still it was like oh come on man but
it's crazy how many times you'll go back
to the well sometimes when somebody's
tricking you you know [ __ ] tricking you
[ __ ] drinking bobby cotton dude thank
you so much for coming in meg good luck
out there at the raves um and thank you
first of all i just want to say thank
you so much for
just uh
for getting things back to their
original form man for repairing things
that need to be repaired in the world
yeah and thanks for having me i've
really enjoyed this yeah this is awesome
man thank you so much for uh
for your time man and um we'll share rob
socials if you guys want to hit him up
and yeah that's trauma cleanup man rob
cotton thank you bob thank you
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones
but it's gonna take
a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my hands
[Music]
built